[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing what is arguably the most
important date
in harry potter law as a whole and that
is the day
that lord voldemort traveled to godric's
hollow to murder the potters
i'm covering this video today in
commemoration of the day that it
happened
39 years and one day ago most of you
probably know why voldemort traveled
there on that fateful night
to kill baby harry but what some of you
might not entirely understand
is why it had to be done why did he have
to kill the potters
wasn't he the all-powerful dark lord
with legions of followers
what immediate threat did this family
pose to him
the answer to this question lies inside
of the famous
prophecy the prophecy of course refers
to the prediction
foretold by sybil trulani in hogsmeade
pub in the year 1980
we know sybil as the professor of
divination at hogwarts
and we know that she has a track record
of successful predictions
predicting at the end of the 93-94
school year that petticrew would escape
and that voldemort would return however
she was not always so successful
and in 1980 found herself in the
hogsmeade pub with dumbledore
interviewing for her post as professor
while her poor reputation preceded her
dumbledore gave her a chance because she
was the great granddaughter
of famous seer cassandra trelawny during
her interview
a disappointed and unimpressed
dumbledore began to lose interest
when suddenly sibyl entered into a
trance in her trance-like state
sibyl spoke of the famous prophecy that
we all know
explaining that voldemort would be
defeated it spoke of a boy
that would be born at the end of july
that possessed the power to defeat the
dark lord
himself what dumbledore and sybil did
not know
however was that snape who was then a
death eater was eavesdropping at the
door
this simple fact immediately placed
sybil in great danger from voldemort
and in an effort to protect her
dumbledore hired her for the position
at hogwarts the entire prophecy is as
follows
the one with the power to vanquish the
dark lord approaches
born to those who have thrice to fight
him born as the seventh month dies
and the dark lord will mark him as his
equal but he will have power the dark
lord
knows not and either must die at the end
of the other
for neither can live while the other
survives the one with the power to
vanquish the dark lord
will be born as the seventh month dies
what's interesting about snape
eavesdropping is that he did not hear
the prophecy
in its entirety and only told voldemort
what he remembered
because of this he missed out very
important details like the fact that
harry would be marked as his equal
and that he would possess unknown power
snape also
almost immediately regretted his
decision to tell voldemort
as he quickly realized that it would
place the life of lily evans
the only girl he ever loved in jeopardy
severus snape had gone down
a dark path and he was a death eater but
he had also always been infatuated with
lily
harry's mother and actually took action
to protect her
from voldemort's attack on the potter
residence he knew that he would have to
do something
if he wanted to save her life and with
nowhere else to go
snape turned his enemy at the time the
leader of the opposition
albus dumbledore well severus what
message does lord voldemort have for me
no no message i'm here on my own account
snape was rigging his hands he looked a
little mad with his straggling black
hair
flying around him i i come with a
warning
no a request please what request could a
death eater make of me
the the prophecy the prediction trelawny
ah yes said dumbledore how much did you
relay to lord voldemort
everything everything i heard said snape
that is why it is for that reason he
thinks it means
lily evans the prophecy did not refer to
a woman
said dumbledore it spoke of a boy born
at the end of july
you know what i mean he thinks it means
her son he is going to hunt her down
heal them all if she means so much to
you said dumbledore
surely lord voldemort will spare her
could you not ask for mercy for the
mother
in exchange for the son i have i have
asked him
you disgust me said dumbledore and harry
had never heard so much contempt in his
voice
snape seemed to shrink a little you do
not care then
about the deaths of her husband and
child they can die
as long as you have what you want snape
said nothing
but merely looked up at dumbledore snape
was a desperate man
and at this point in time would have
done anything to protect the woman
that he loved lily evans snape told
dumbledore that he would do
anything to ensure that lily was
protected and this was a testament to
snape's devotion
to lily he dropped his death heater
status and the life that he had built
for himself
in an instant when he found out that
lilly was in danger
however snape's last-ditch effort to
protect lily was too little too late
and ultimately proved unsuccessful with
the information that had been provided
to him by snape
voldemort came to the conclusion that
harry was the boy that the prophecy was
talking about
lily and james were some of dumbledore's
most powerful supporters
and integral members of the order of the
phoenix which meant that voldemort
already had them on its radar snape who
hated james potter vehemently
helped him with his intel the only other
option for a child
that posed his threat to him was neville
longbottom who was born on the 30th of
july
but voldemort firmly believed that it
was harry this brings us to voldemort's
next move
partially driven by ignorance and
partially by foolishness
voldemort believed that he would be able
to circumvent the prophecy by murdering
harry
on wednesday october 31st voldemort
traveled to the town of godric's hollow
where the potter family lived
it was here that voldemort in an attempt
to murder harry
ended up murdering james and lily
voldemort did not go there with the
intention of murdering harry's parents
as to him they were no immediate threat
however
they did get in the way which meant that
he would have to dispose of them
he had a very specific goal and that was
to kill harry
when he entered their home he first
ended the life of james potter
and then began making his way towards
lily and baby harry
when voldemort approached lily he asked
her to step aside
and let him have harry to somewhat honor
snape's wishes
he told lily that if she stepped aside
then he would spare her life
but obviously lily's main priority was
protecting harry
because she would not get out of the way
she was murdered by voldemort's killing
curse
next voldemort turned his wand on harry
he knew that he was moments away from
killing the only boy
or wizard that was a threat to him and
his regime however
what would happen next is something he
could never have predicted
as after firing and killing cursed harry
his curse rebounded back at him
this was a result of alarming sacrifice
that lily had made
sacrificial protection when the curse
came back at him
it destroyed him and it marked the end
of voldemort for a time
but it also tragically marked the end of
the potters
this date october 31st marked the end of
the first wizarding war
secured harry's reputation as the boy
who lived and marked the point at which
snape's allegiance completely shifted
this was a prominent date in history as
it allowed the wizarding world
at least for a time to get back to
normal during the first wizarding war
voldemort really peaked in terms of
power sure he was able to secure
followers and get his body back in the
second war
but in the first war he really had a
strong secure
confident grasp on the wizarding world
he knew that he was in control
and everyone else knew it too this is
what makes this date
so important as if the events of this
day didn't occur
voldemort's rule over the wizarding
world may have just lasted
forever that's it for this video
do you guys agree that this is the
single most important date
in harry potter law let me know in the
comment section below
until next time it does not do to dwell
on dreams
and forget to live
[Music]
you